Compadre of mine W he's been with the
NFL Network for 11
years 11 years Super Bowl winning head
coach and now uh author the Q factor The
elusive search for the next great NFL
quarterback available now where all
books are sold none other than Brian bck
how are you Brian bck how are you doing
sir you when you say it like that 11
years it it is I feel old like well
that's a lot of those are a lot of words
no it's a lot of word it's well you know
it's a lot of BS too Brian I'm not
saying that's what you do but you know
that's what we do for a living is you
know we we we feel but we do believe
everything that we say and so why why uh
why this book walk me through um where
you sat down I'm going to write a book
I'm going to figure out what it is and
this is what it is the Q factor The
elusive search for the next great NFL
quarterback yeah my co-author James Dale
who's from Baltimore approached me prior
to the 2018 draft and and put a very
simple question to me why is it we screw
this up so much I mean you look at just
in relative terms recent in what world
do you take Mitchell trabis before you
take Patrick Mahomes and deshaan Watson
this one in what world do you take yeah
what world do you take Josh Rose and
then head of Lamar Jackson so and he was
asking that he's a very intellectually
curious guy and he was asking him from a
very naive perspective how does that
happen today's analytics and and with
all the resources that you throw out it
how and as we've talked about many times
Rich you take a first round quarterback
it is a 5050 proposition and it ought to
be more than that so we used the 2018
class which was supposed to be this you
know best class ever since 2004 or 1983
with Kelly and Marino and Elway and we
said okay well let's and and the book is
written in real time okay here's the
evaluations going in here's how they
were drafted and here's what's
transpired over the last two years H to
see if we could look at and analyze the
process that leads us to and if you look
at that class right now it's kind kind
of harboring at 5050 Baker Mayfield
don't know Sam darnold not I'm hard
sorry to tell you this not looking real
good Josh Allen looks great Josh rosen's
already been waved out of the league and
Lamar Jackson's the MVP so yeah it was
an interesting class to use that as a
backdrop to look at this process so what
is what have you learned Brian and you
know I know you've you've you've joked
with me before on this show on NFL
Network as well the name Kyle bowler
always uh on occasion will will be
brought up uh to you and with you and
have so what have you GLE what's to
glean um on that very well clearly and
it was fascinating I'm also doing a
series of podcasts around the book and
I've had a chance to visit with a number
of people from Bill Po and of course to
Azie new who I worked with Hall of
Famers and listening to people like John
Elway and Glen Dawson Dan Fouts and Dan
John or Joe Montana I mean list goes on
and on and okay what is it that makes
the quarterback position and and clearly
three things when you look in and look
at the the the whole perspective one
there's the physical attributes more
importantly there's the mental and the
emotional makeup and then thirdly it's
where did they go and that's really what
comes home to me as you go back over the
last 20 25 years and you look at you
look at first round bus I don't care if
it's Vince Young Demarcus Russell Tim
Couch ailly Smith it goes on and on they
could all physically play it wasn't the
physical part of the game that tripped
them up typically it was either they
mentally or emotionally couldn't handle
the transition doesn't mean there was
anything wrong with them mentally they
just didn't have the wherewithal to do
it at a NFL level at a very unique and
demanding position and or did they go to
the wrong place at the right at the
wrong time so that combination the
latter two is what really brings you
back to looking at okay what's the
criteria we're looking at and and what
are certain non-negotiables to use a
professional uh Talent Hunter's term you
establish that going in and so often
when you look at it as we've said it
before you know that non-negotiable
becomes very negotiated and need is a
terrible evaluator and how often do we
take a guy that should be a second or
third round pick and pull him up into
the first round I love that need is a
terrible evaluator Brian Billy that's
perfect way to put it and you know so
let's just quickly hit on on Mayfield
who's taking on the Cowboys um this this
uh this coming weekend uh I guess
returning to the place where he was
drafted that was the night the draft
night in that in that building um and I
would if you had told me that night if
Mayo had leaned over to me that night or
or you know or schfer had said on his
ESPN set and leaned over to me prior to
it with Ian Rapaport or what have you
and said to me hey Mayfield is going to
have four different head coaches over
the next three years four different ones
I would have been like well really what
he's got no shot so have we been unable
to evaluate him I know you said you
still kind of like shrug emoji on him
but uh what is your evaluation based on
everything that you just said about uh
showing up and needing a system needing
a right spot and sometimes somebody's
Talent can overcome all that to become a
great quarterback where do you stand on
the subject of this uh quarterback Bri
yeah well let let's go back to our
non-negotiables let's go back to our
three areas and the two most critical
the mental and emotional and obviously
he's he's got that Swagger and that
confidence
but is indeed is it proportion to where
he's just Reckless and throwing the ball
up hence the one toone touchdown
interception ratio or is it truly that
athletic arrogance that you've got to
have and I say that in a complimentary
way all great quarterbacks have a
certain athletic arrogance about them a
confidence that yes I could do this but
so you can't combine that with with the
you know the Chinese fire drill that has
been his upbringing in the NFL with all
that's going on in Cleveland that's
that's that's almost a a combination
that can't be overcome so the question
is is it truly is it truly Mayfield's
fault or lack of ability and now with
Kevin stefansky will it even out and we
will we see it or even you know or is
indeed that's this is not the answer or
no he clearly doesn't have what it takes
so this is a tough one it's it's tough
to put the thumbs down on him but he's
he's fighting an uphill battle right now
well I mean and and Josh Allen is is
taking a major step forward this year
and you could say that the bills did the
right thing in surrounding him with the
people to help him and an offense that's
just for him and and that that's that's
that's clicking and working and then
there is the case of the guy who is the
reigning MVP of this league now 0 and9
in games in which he's trailed at
halftime and uh we saw once again the
supposed Achilles heel unless it isn't
uh and I'd love to put this in front of
you certainly having a front row seat
there in Baltimore Bryant that uh all
you got to do is get Lamar down by two
scores and you got you got the Ravens
right where you want them what what do
you make of Lamar Jackson on that front
and this offense that they are running
mostly to success in Baltimore yeah you
always hear after a surprising loss that
for a team it's okay now we have a
template okay we have a temp well yes
okay here's the template for beating the
Ravens one you don't give up the big
play and clearly Kansas City did a good
job he was 0 for five with throws big
you know plays down the field didn't
have any completion over 20 yards two
you got to keep him within the pocket
You' got to bring that fifth and sixth
man so that he has to operate primarily
from the pocket and third offensively
you have to keep them off the field you
have to have an offense that can click
that away so I my response is absolutely
there is a template the problem is part
of that template you have to have
Patrick Mahomes okay that's because you
don't have that part of the template so
let's let's slow down here and just say
okay yeah we can just roll this thing
out um so that is a big part of it and
Lamar Jackson I think uh that is
something that he and that was a big
focus in the offseason improving his
throws his completion percentage and his
throws particularly from the numbers to
the outside and against a team that had
all phases of it going in Kansas City
they couldn't do it now they've got
three games basically three home games
they're at Washington which is a bus
ride uh then Cincinnati then then at
Philly which is also a bus ride so
virtually 3 home games um against three
you know struggling football teams so I
think they got a chance to get their
Swagger back they're going they're
probably going to run up a bunch of
points and a bunch of yards uh and feel
good about themselves but clearly that
that's going to be the challenge because
they know that's the hard thing about
the loss the other day at home in
Baltimore that sitting at the end of
that that tunnel to the Super Bowl is
going to be Kansas City likely and can
indeed you put it together the next time
and win Brian bilck here on the Rich
Eisen show and it's kind of fitting that
you're joining us right now after Brent
musberger and the reason why I say that
is I thought of you when Brent musberger
talked about the Patriots taking on the
Raiders who he's calling the games for
that uh that Darren Waller was taken out
of the game by bich because he always
takes away the one thing that you want
to do and I I I give you the floor I
this is one of my favorite things that
you ever say when you hear belich takes
away the one thing that you want go for
it Brian good yeah you you you know what
I'm going to say that and he is he's
brilliant he takes away the one thing
that can beat you they take away the
best thing they do compared to the rest
of us that are evidently covering all
the decoys or or or deciding to Let's no
let's take on the weakest link and and
let the good guys really beat us so yeah
it is but but they are brilliant at it
and they do you know they're very
focused on exactly what to do to take
that that element away from you and
evidently I was one of those that
couldn't figure it I'm running around
chasing
decoys well they are uh a a a a a
fascinating new home for Cam Newton
whose 2015 version uh of him has shown
up 2020 in New England and they have now
got five different guys including him
who run the ball they're they seem to
have changed things around there based
on who they have like they have done the
the work to figure out what to do here
that's different than obviously the
previous quarterback they're a goat I I
they might be the most fascinating story
and in in the League this year and
saying a lot because Tom Brady is in
Tampa with Bruce arens and the rest of
that offense uh Brian what do you what
do you make of what is going on in New
England yeah who and you could kind of
figure this out because who adapts
better to their circumstances than New
England I mean even when Brady was there
what would we see one week he'd come out
and they'd go okay we're going to throw
it 50 times because we just think that's
what we're going going to do and then
the next week come out and go well we're
not going to throw it at all we're going
to run the ball 45 times because we
think we can run on these guys so
they're they they built themselves on
that flexibility even from week to week
and you knew Josh McDaniel would ad just
okay here's a different set of of of uh
skill sets with Cam Newton we're gonna
find go back and look at what he does
best uh we're going to duplicate that
we're going to expand it in with some of
the things we do and more importantly
you talk about the transformation cam
has gone through the trans inform he
sounds like a patriot now doesn't he I
mean in terms of the post game and just
everything about him um left emotional
and it's you know he gets into the
bichan kind of okay I'm not g to be a
distraction I'm gonna kind of fall in
line with the party line so you got to
give him credit for kind of falling into
the Patriot Way way as well so uh I'm
gonna finish up this conversation uh
with you sir uh with a Sports Talk Radio
question since that's what we are on
right right now the Q factor The elusive
search for the next great NFL
quarterback is available where all books
are sold um and you are the co-author
James Dale right is that the your your
your Co okay it's also available on
audio which I want you to get ricked
because I want you to have to sit in
your car and listen to me talk for 10
straight hours sounds great sounds great
uh again I I I I'm I'm all for that
Brian there's no question um so I'll ask
you the Sports Talk Radio question right
here the next great NFL quarterback um
is either Joe burrow or Trevor Lawrence
you got to choose one who do you think
that is oh boy wow boy that's a tough
one you get but these are two brilliant
quarterbacks are both good athletes um
you you've got already a few here I I'll
I'll I'll so you could think about it
I'll I'll I'll tap dance a little bit
you've already gotten three games of
burrow in already and you're seeing he
can wing it around and he does take the
hit I mean and he's he's he's tough and
Trevor Lawrence I'm already thinking is
somebody who follows the Jets like I
love Sam darnold but if if he's
available you know you know Sam is like
Josh Rosen 2.0 you know what I mean like
uh with all due respect so now I give
you the floor right here yeah just just
the fact that I'm hesitating tells you I
think these guys are touching that's how
good I think Trevor Lawrence is I'm
gonna go with Joe burrow who I like I
love the fact he's on Pace to throw the
ball better than 650 times I know which
he may he may get killed but you turn so
the learning curve that's a good thing
because he's going to be a much better
quarterback come 2021 for having go gone
through these experiences uh and just
the fact that he's already got the leg
up on it and he's shown that he hasn't
wilted under that kind of pressure of
throwing it but I I think these guys are
touching I like both these guys of
course uh but you if you choose one you
take burrow you take Joe burrow yeah
just because he's I've got more more
data with him that's that's the cheaters
way out but I'll go with bro all right
if I got an answer I'll answer
congrat I appreciate that you know I
always have to answer your question
right Brian I I and I appreciate I'm
just saying I'm saying right that's
right you're not just saying you're
saying thanks again for uh for calling
in uh again everybody should go get uh
the book where books are sold and and
then of course you want to listen to
Brian bilck for 10 straight hours get
the audio version of it the key factor
The elusive search for the next great
NFL quarterback best to you and your
family Brian let's chat again soon all
right you too sir you got it right back
at you coach bck to follow him on
Twitter as I do please do that